and I think it depends on how it all
like how your brain receives all the
information if isolated chick's hot she
21 like oh she's hot but you have a
daughter and then your daughter brings
like her friends they're just your
daughter's friends so you don't start
going oh bring her
more so gross
[Music]
dude a Kentucky Republican introduced
legislation that would amend the state's
law so a person who had sex with their
first cousin would no longer be
criminally liable for incest
ye we should have certain laws for a
reason I don't agree with this before
withdrawing it and claiming an error was
made during the dang it Anthony there
you go
again I saw this I reposted on my story
oh really what did you say I said um
he's four inet so I was like that's
because none of y'all had hot cousins
B Ryan did Ryan
did sure as hell did so hot so I mean
put your conspiracy hat back on what do
you think about having sex with your
first cousin
I congressmen and women are idiots
they're just not smart people like I
that's the priority huh I think you're
going to dunk that hard for a lack of
word I've got the opportunity to meet
many they are extremely under impressive
people wow really like not overly smart
not overly well spoken just like people
you like really This Guy's in charge
like I get that feeling all the time
when I meet Congressman but it makes
sense to me though because I actually
think that the best and brightest will
go to the private sector like why would
you okay if you're unless you have a hug
why a public servant no 100% why would
you like unless you care like it's like
think about it right like why do people
become cops a handful really want to be
a cop cuz they [__] believe but most
of them I don't know what else to do
same with teachers a handful of them
really [__] want to teach they love
that [__] they're passionate and the
rest of them I think it might be a solid
job right and I think it's the same
approach to the public sector who the
[__] wakes up one day and goes I'm going
to go work at the DMV that's my
dream right like no it's a solid job it
pays the bills family lineage thing and
I think that's the same thing with
politics dude you [__] work your way
up as a like you go you I don't know
you're a city city clerk you know people
coming in with their permits and [__]
you're just signing [__] you're like
this [__] boring man I'm going go
higher I'mma Elevate whatever right not
all some are great but a lot of them are
just very underqualified for their
positions and I think this situation and
I bet you this was probably in a part of
a bill cuz the bills are so large and
there's so much language in a bill and
then there's like sections of bills and
the News will be like oh look at what he
approved or what he agreed to but it's
like three lines on like a 500 page Bill
like they're not reading this they have
no idea what's in there and like oh [__]
I can't believe I co-signed that because
no no Congressman would really like
knowingly support that right like that's
political suicide it probably got snuck
in there somewhere and um or they got
paid yeah or he got paid to do it which
they would do if someone paid him enough
but the reality is like if you if that
was your public thing chance of getting
reelected is really small and that's all
they especially if you talk about the
House of Representatives which is
two-year terms they literally live their
lives on how to get elected the next
term cuz only two years versus Senate
which is 5 years which is like all right
I'm actually going to try to do some
work but there's less of them but on on
the um House of Representative side like
they're always fighting for another
election so it seems like something
someone made a mistake with although
it's so stupid like who who's going to
put the name on that yeah but so you
don't believe that it's cool no I mean
you know I haven't seen your
cousin that's my first cousin that's my
cousin you got to look at your own
cousin I mean no I mean so if I saw her
then I wouldn't judge you as much you
know I mean my friend said oh that's
true yeah he had my friend said he had a
hot cousin pretty banging he him yeah he
my friend say he had a hot cousin and
then remember Bart yeah was he right I
saw the picture and she was hot not mad
it's a little weird to be the cousin
saying that huh all right hot take first
cousin that's incest second cousin oh
day bra I'll be [__] that
[__] what exactly is a second cousin is
that a cousin of a cousin or second
cousin is like uh let's say like my
parents my Dad's cousin had a kid their
kid oh that's even okay in the animal
world second cousin by marriage even
first cousins are okay in animal world
no all right all right all right
brothers and sisters Animal World third
cousin twice
removed but same age somehow or adopted
sister what is twice removed mean
adopted sister is totally fine isn't
it no well conceptually it's like at
least that's not true incest where
there's like a DNA disparity yeah that's
what I'm talking about like the risk is
if it's just weirdness then all the
above but if you're just talking about a
kid surviving the yeah cuz we're talking
about that's not that's not your blood
lineage but third cousin is like [__]
12th you yeah but adopted is nothing you
yeah but you grew up together so you
might love each other no that's too oh
you guys are ancal dude oh so you're
saying that you impregnated your adopted
sister the day she got adopted if who's
the guy that married his adopted
daughter Wood Allen yeah big fan big fan
of it's a good move as a powerful
move he makes a good film that was weird
that means he's a pet off yeah
daughter's weird
though she was from China too wasn't she
it wasn't nearly as lambasted as you
would think though people didn't really
care back
that wait are they still together yeah
alive and well oh they're both well it's
true love now she aged out of the hey
there you go how long does it take to
prove the true love I think after the
first year you're good dude it's weird
there's there's nothing you can say to
make me okay with that that one's weird
is it still weird if she's past
45 yeah it's always weird I mean I think
that's a definition of grooming yeah it
is you're literally parental figure yeah
yeah cuz everything that you've done
prior to that you have to like look at
with a different view oh that's awful
that's so weird so he was grooming her
while he was grooming her oh well yeah
probably yeah apparently she also
alleged that he molested her at age
seven which is Weir chist I mean that's
literally grooming saw that coming yeah
we're not surprised best example of it
that's [__] crazy dude that's that's
so wrong but he never he never paid any
type of like price for that right no cuz
they're married yeah yeah they never
nothing ever that's the ultimate
punishment right there but they're still
together punishment that he has to live
with her stuck with her forever that's
only way to like survive
the cancellation well he's a little he's
a little gry listed Now isn't he like
from today's well remember the uh the
Filipino kid that was uh he was in like
high school and he dated the the white
lady who was his teacher that's
different when it's a high school boy
and a hot lady yeah yeah but then like
she went they she went to jail he waited
for her and then they got married
afterwards and now they're making a
movie about him and they had kids he was
Filipino I think he was thought he was
Simone or something he got the little
stash dude [__] he a little Filipino
guy Filipino
a lot of girls can't resist your guys'
dicks the toxicity is too strong too
strong dude [__] they're too costic I
don't know about you guys but if I grow
up with someone right it's kind of like
when Lions grow up with like golden
retrievers family dog like you don't eat
your family yeah you might [__] him
no oh come on even if she's a 10 no
that'll be how would you know she's a
10 cuz she's hot as [__]
how are you able to ra her what if you
watch him take a shower and you're like
God damn it but when you're kid why you
a 10 in there when you're kids and you
grow up with the roles of like brother
and sister adopted or not it's still
[__] weird yeah I think you
desexualize them eventually eventually
you do yeah really yeah I think so hell
yeah dude there's girls that I thought
were attractive and then like I get to
know them and I'm all like man you ain't
that oh you're gross now yeah yeah yeah
yeah 100% 100% is it okay to hook up
with your foster sister [__] yeah no
wait
what foster sister so if you live in a
foster home okay wait no no you don't I
think that's been a dream of mine where
my parents get a divorce right and then
my mom remarries and then like and he's
hot and then
like yeah that's good no they have a
daughter and then like like like he has
a daughter and like step step it's like
Brady bun [__] step step is different
but it's like but she's hot as [__] and
then we're like oh let's we're just
getting to know each other the movie so
hard yeah I feel like if you grow up
with somebody versus like you you're you
you're a teenager or an adult and then
you have something like then it's a
little different but if you grow up with
someone as supposed to be your sister
role or cousin role that's a little
funny ask a cat and a dog that grew up
as a puppy and a kitten you think
they're going to they're not going to
like that [__] no what if you're like
let's say that you work at like the boys
and girls club and you're mentoring some
kid and then they grow up to be 18 and
then you start dating them is that weird
that's a little weird that is weird
that's great but but they're
like it depends on the relationship
they're a nine and they like you I think
it would have to be how old are you it
would be it would have to be those
things where like you go to summer and
you come back and she got titties over
the summer and you're like oh [__] dude
you ain't no kid no more what's up dude
like pulled my muscle
dude you know why I don't know like that
it's weird is because like my classmates
I was I mean like that's the only
refence I have right is like you go
you're like you know sophomore junior
[__] summer break you come back and
then you're just like what happened to
you girl that's true that's a real thing
that's a real thing yeah such a hot way
to say it you went from like rectangular
to like hourglass but do you think for
example when you're and for everybody
when you're like 50 years old you can
objectively look at like a 21y old and
be like she's fine
yeah cuz you become 20 silent longer
stay everybody hold that again I thought
you was supposed to say a trick question
but that was a pretty straightforward
yeah so you can right yeah of course
hell yeah but what if what if at that
particular age and you're objectively
able to see like a 21-year-old as like
dang she's fine but she also happens to
be maybe younger than like your
daughter I think you can separate though
twoo I think what Happ the
game no because I think what happens in
our mind is like we become 25 oh so you
go when I was a young whipper snapper
you would have been fell on the ball and
and I think it depends on how it all
like how your brain receives all the
information if isolated chick's hot
she's 21 like oh she's hot but you have
a daughter and then your daughter brings
like her friends they're just your
daughter's friends so you don't start oh
[__] bring her
more so gross
dude did you want to come on vacation
with us separately you saw us going like
dang she's fine buil a relationship and
then your daughter brings her over she
like hey look meet my friend my brain
would go
recategorize I'll tell you what a great
guy what a great guy if my mom's pretty
old it's all theoretical by the
way but but guess which parts are't I'll
tell you this cuz I'm not agist all
right same example but older my mom's a
[__] too old but imagine if she was
50 and a cougar she's like 70 something
so if she was
50 and then her home girls came and
there was a hot ass 50-year-old I
wouldn't be like oh you're like my mom's
age she's still [__] hot yeah true
but even though your mom brought her
over you wouldn't associate that with
your mom's friend just like he's saying
right now I think hot is hot hot is hot
dude like when you see a celebrity so
hot is hot right so now they're your
steps sister oh see that's weird then or
now that's the article they're your
second cousin I think once you know them
as family I think that's no matter what
changes your lenses it does but I think
it is true though like if if you like
that context that you said of like if
you had a daughter and she brought her
friend over and then like I think that's
just in my head my brain can't compute
that it's like it's a completely
different categ
your yeah but even then it's like nah
bro like here's one for you then let's
say you're a a modeling casting agent
and you're trying to cast for uh teen
like club wear and then the the boss
goes I want you to pick the six hottest
models for this brand how do you tell
which kids to
pick damn wait how old are these teens
15 14 well first off why am I working
for teen club wear teen shouldn't be
going to the club man you got cancelled
for saying too much [__] here that's
where you ended up and because you've
been to an underage club before when you
were a teen so you know the demo you
might need to teleport your brain back
to your 15-year-olds okay is that what
you're doing hey that's what they're all
doing when they're there huh on island
huh I think to me just teleporting huh
yeah IED them
now okay good
looking it's the same right like there's
a point where they're like someone looks
like a child and they're not like
medable and then there's a point above
that where they're like I don't know why
we said medable 14year old girl I wish
we didn't do
that could have just said hot or pretty
you know I'm
saying anything but made video the
[Music]
video